des spécialistes de l'innovation
technologique et numérique réunies
autour de médecins et de sportifs
deuxième édition à l'ufr simone veil
pour ce symposium dédiée au sport et à
la santé
il ya un lien très fort entre certaines
maladies et leurs traitements d'ailleurs
l'assurance maladie prend en charge pour
partie certains sports en prescription
et ça s'appelle une francs sur
ordonnance
ça c'est sûr certains sports la marche
le
l'aviron est par exemple le golf tout
dernièrement en vue des jeux olympiques
en 2024 l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines organise ce type de rendez vous
depuis l'année dernière nous réussissons
à mettre en place et des actions
transversales qui sont très
intéressantes
effectivement pour cela nous appuyons
sur sur les enseignants chercheurs sur
les médecins de l'université sur le
service aussi universitaire de médecine
au programme pour cette journée des
tables rondes mais aussi des ateliers
plusieurs sports était à l'honneur du
vélo de l'aviron encore du golfe ce
simulateur permet notamment d'améliorer
son swing exactement comme sur un
practice de golf coup je vois ma balle
qui vole ça va permettre de voir à la
fois la vitesse de la balle la rotation
de la balle
ça va permettre de voir l' axe du club
si on l intérieur extérieur ça va
définir toutes là tout ce que le golfeur
a besoin pour s'améliorer
l'ufr de santé simone veil vous donne
d'ores et déjà rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour une nouvelle thématique
autour du sport et de la santé